Global tensions un reforms and other
issues sto the agenda at this year's
nonaligned movement or n representatives
from 120 countries are here to forge a
greater say in international Affairs
when n was formed the priority was
decolonization which was achieved now we
have geopolitics and N non-aligned
movement concept does not mean
neutrality doesn't mean neutrality now
what these countries are doing is what
we are trying to Define as strategic
nonalignment at the heart of discussions
is the war between Israel and
Palestine foreign ministers adopted a
resolution calling for a ceasefire and
unhindered humanitarian assistance for
Palestinians they also support the
ongoing genocide case against Israel at
the international court of justice the
foreign ministers struggled to find the
right language to address the killings
in Gaza but agree that genocide is now a
legal matter that needs to be decided by
the international court of
justice Palestinian Representatives
called this a summit of solidarity in
light of the global situation and what's
happening in
Ukraine and the fight by the big guys
and in light of the aggression against
our people and morally exposing the
double standard of the West Nam is have
as an opportunity now to play a leading
role after the United Nations n is the
largest Coalition of States worldwide
delegates here say it's a powerful block
whose voice cannot be ignored Katherine
soy Al jaer
kalala make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer